uh hi there steve kaufman here today i
want to talk about a subject that comes
up all the time it's motivation
i think motivation is the number one
most important
uh
element
factor in language learning success
i just finished participating in a
a google plus hangout with uh i don't
know seven or eight other polyglots
people who on the internet
regularly post comments like i do
talking about their experience of
language learning and it was hosted by
david manseray who lives in london
and i'm going to leave a
link to it here in the box underneath
the video and if you are interested
please go and listen it was done using
uh google plus hangout technology we're
still kind of ironing out the best
practices for this
technology things like leaving your
microphone on mute when you're not
speaking
but
here were seven or eight nine people who
are obviously very motivated to learn
languages and we were asked several
questions by david
about the different methods that we use
and what we found useful and not useful
and so forth
um one thing that was interesting was
that um
most of the people answered that
there was one question what techniques
that other people use do you not find
useful or something to that effect and a
number of people said that they don't
find it useful to do shadowing they
don't find anki or space repetition or
flash cards useful so that and yet there
are people who find those things useful
and i think what i took out of that was
that if you are motivated
you will find the learning techniques
that work best for you and it really
doesn't matter whether you flash guard
or use anki or use something else
most of the people there
basically said they like to listen and
read
they like to engage with things that
were meaningful and interesting to them
and i think that's a very important part
of motivation
i think that in many cases the
traditional method of teaching is quite
demotivating because it focuses on the
nuts and bolts of the language
trying to get you to pronounce correctly
at an early stage or trying to get you
to remember
grammatical patterns at an early stage
and because this is extremely difficult
to do
people get frustrated
so but yet i still leaving that aside i
still ask myself for example i've
mentioned before that
immigrants to canada do very poorly at
these government-sponsored
language schools
i would think they basically achieve
you know nothing that they couldn't
achieve
more effectively on their own if they
were motivated
i i would think for a motivated person
the time spent in the classroom is
actually a waste of time because you're
in there listening to 10 15 20 other
people struggle with the language
whereas if you are genuinely motivated
you could learn
using resources on the internet if
you're living in a place where the
language is spoken you're just
surrounded by
uh you know resources that can help you
learn but so few people are motivated
and so i asked myself here we have these
nine
keeners and and then subsequent to that
i had a discussion in chinese with
nicholas from sweden who's 18 years old
and who speaks flawless english spanish
and now has been at chinese he says for
four months and he speaks like wow
extremely well again a very motivated
person
so why is it that some people are so
motivated and other people
uh sort of say yeah like i spoke to a
lady the other day at a chinese
restaurant we were speaking in chinese
and she said yeah you know i've been
here three years and but uh you know and
i really want to learn but uh you know
i'm having a lot of trouble and stuff
and she can hardly speak english
and uh
you know if you were really motivated
like i didn't want to pro but like how
much time do you actually spend
with english how much effort do you put
into it
so that i think there's various levels
of motivation there's all there are
those people who aren't interested at
all
and i knew a lot of those when i lived
in japan for example uh
europeans north americans who lived
there and made absolutely no effort to
get beyond the you know konichiwa in
japanese so there's the zero motivation
group then there's the people who say
yeah i would love to be able to speak
spanish
uh but they don't you know they sort of
at a certain level they're motivated but
they either aren't sufficiently
motivated to push
or they become easily discouraged and
this was another point that was raised
by luca
that the initial period with the
language can be quite discouraging
because it's so difficult you basically
you can't make sense of the language
nothing
you don't understand and stuff
and so it is important to persevere
and
and get break through that to the next
level now in my own experience i find
that the initial period in some ways is
quite rewarding because very quickly you
know the word for dog horse cow
you know some things whereas previously
you knew nothing
but then comes that very long period
where you have to move from
some understanding of the language to
actually reaching a comfortable level of
fluency so i think that intermediate to
advanced stage takes a much longer
period of time
than getting from zero to some
understanding in the language and i
think there too people lose their
motivation
and there again my advice always is to
give yourself credit for more than you
think you know for being better than you
think you are but also stay with
activities that are interesting and
follow your interests now that's
assuming that people have interest if
you have no interest in any aspect then
probably you're not going to be so
motivated but
i just felt coming off that discussion
with those polyglots and also with
nicholas i said there's a small group of
people maybe those are the people who
watch my videos
people who are into learning more than
one language
that's a very small number and then
there's a very large number of people
who
to varying degrees but like to learn a
language
but they aren't motivated enough now why
is that is it that we have to make it
easier for them to achieve some success
that they could feed off that success to
become more motivated
like that's the thing i always struggle
with how do you
you know motivate people
assuming that there's some degree of
interest in speaking another language
you know is it a matter of convincing
them that they'll feel so much happier
if they speak that other language
uh you know there's making the reward
more palpable to them
um
you know i think of um
you know again i i was talking to
someone in in europe and there
unemployed people receive 600 euros a
month but if they attend a language
school they get 800 euros a month so
they're they are motivated to attend the
language school but this person told me
most people don't learn very much there
so they're the motivation drives them to
attend the language school six hours a
day with 20 people in the classroom
uh two so if they do that for a year
that's 1200 euros
um 200 additional what did i say 12 2
400 euros
maybe you could motivate them by saying
if you achieve level x in the language
we will give you 2 400 euros rather than
motivating them to go to school
when in fact the schools are very often
quite unsuccessful at teaching the
language maybe the motivation should be
if you achieve a level x we will give
you 2 400 euros now you still have to
find people willing to come up with the
money to motivate people but even if you
don't get the money the rewards for
being comfortable in the language to me
are so obvious
in terms of professional opportunities
in terms of
cultural enrichment in terms of being
able to make friends and travel in
different countries that it's like
getting a bonus of 2 500 euros or 5 000
euros it's worth more than 5 000 euros
so i guess the question is how do you
make i guess how do you initially make
that
that uh achievement of being comfortable
in another language seem
genuinely attractive to people so that
they're just committed to it and then
how do you maintain their motivation by
making sure that they do activities that
are interesting to them
and then how do you ensure that they
achieve some degree of success so that
that will in turn
encourage them to continue and i guess
part of that is to not allow them to be
discouraged
that allow them to recognize that it
takes a long time to learn a language
so
i mean these are some of the things that
that
you know i often wonder about i mean
potentially i think you know if if
there's a very small percentage of
people who are very motivated motivated
to learn languages how do we make that
10 times the number so i'd be interested
in hearing your comments about this
whole issue
of motivation and how to motivate people
beyond the sort of i call ourselves the
little ghetto of polyglots but into the
sort of average population how do you
get more people interested in learning
languages and get them to stay with the
program until they achieve success so i
look forward to hearing
any comments thank you for listening